ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you
thank you everybody please have a seat
thank you very much let me begin by
thanking dr. Jared Cohen and the entire
Carnegie Mellon community for welcoming
me once again and for the terrific work
that he and the administration faculty
and staff do here each and every day I
also want to acknowledge your
outstanding mayor who doesn't look any
older than the last time I saw mayor
luke ravenstahl there he is right there
it is great to be back at Carnegie
Mellon and in the beautiful city of
Pittsburgh I love visiting a good sports
town last year I stole Dan Rooney to
serve as my ambassador to Ireland to
make it up I invited both the Steelers
and the Penguins to the white house to
celebrate their championships
seeing how the Blackhawks are headed to
philly tonight with a 2 0 lead and the
Stanley Cup Finals I'm just glad we're
on this side of the state I noticed a
couple people said they were rooting for
the Blackhawks which tells me something
about the rivalry between Pittsburgh and
philly of course we meet here at an
incredibly difficult time for America
among other things it's a time when the
worst environmental disaster of its kind
in our nation's history is threatening
the Gulf Coast and the people who live
there right now stopping this oil spill
and containing its damage is necessarily
the top priority not just of my
administration but i think the entire
country and we're waging this battle
every minute of every day but at the
same time we're continuing our efforts
to recover and rebuild from an economic
disaster that has touched the lives of
nearly every American that's what I want
to talk about today the state of our
economy the future we must seize and the
path we chose to get there it has now
been a little over 16 months since I
took office amid one of the worst
economic storms in our history and to
navigate that storm my administration
was forced to take some dramatic and
unpopular steps these steps have
succeeded in breaking the freefall we're
again moving in the right direction an
economy that was shrinking at an
alarming rate when I became president
has now been growing for three
consecutive quarters after losing an
average of 750,000 jobs a month during
the winter of last year we've now added
jobs for five of the last six months and
we expect to see strong job growth in
friday's report the taxpayer money it
costs to shore up the financial sector
and the auto industry that's being
repaid
and both GM and Chrysler are adding
shifts and operating at a profit so
despite temporary setbacks uncertain
world events and the resulting up and
downs of the market this economy is
getting stronger by the day now that
doesn't mean this recession is by any
means over for the millions of Americans
who are still looking for a job or way
to pay the bills not by a long shot the
devastation created by the deepest
downturn since the Great Depression has
hit people and communities across our
country very hard and it's not going to
be a real recovery until people can feel
it in their own lives in the immediate
future this means doing whatever is
necessary to keep the recovery going in
to spur job growth but in the long term
it means recognizing that for a lot of
class families for entire communities in
some case a sense of Economic Security
has been missing since long before the
recession began over the last decade
these families saw their incomes decline
they saw the cost of things like health
care and college tuition reach record
highs they lived through a so-called
economic expansion that generated slower
job growth than at any prior expansion
since World War two some people have
called the last ten years the Lost
Decade so the anxiety that's out there
today is a new the recession has
certainly made it worse but that feeling
of not being in control of your own
economic future that sense that the
American Dream might slowly be slipping
away that's been around for some time
now and for better or for worse our
generation of Americans has been
buffeted by tremendous forces of
economic change long gone are the days
when a high school diploma could
guarantee a job at a local factory that
when so many
those factories have moved overseas
Pittsburgh the city that once was
defined by the steel industry knows this
better than just about anybody and today
the ability of jobs and entire
industries to relocate where there's
skilled workers and an internet
connection has forced America to compete
like never before from China to India to
Europe other nations have already
realized they're putting a greater
emphasis on math and science and
demanding more from their students some
countries are building high-speed
railroads and expanding broadband access
they're making serious investments in
technology and clean energy because they
want to win the competition for those
jobs so we can't afford to stand pat
while the world races by the United
States of America did not become the
most prosperous nation on earth by sheer
luck or happenstance we got here because
each time a generation of Americans has
faced a changing world we have changed
with it we have not feared our future we
have shaped America does not stand still
we move forward and that's why I've said
that as we emerge from this recession we
can't afford to return to the pre-crisis
status quo we can't go back to an
economy that was too dependent on
bubbles and debt and financial
speculation we can't accept economic
growth that leaves the middle class
owing more and making less we have to
build a new and stronger foundation for
growth and prosperity and that's exactly
what we've been doing for the last 16
months it's a foundation based on
investments in our people and their
future investments in the skills and
education we need to compete investments
in a 21st century infrastructure for
America from
high-speed railroads to high-speed
Internet investments in research and
technology like clean energy that can
lead to new jobs and new exports and new
industries this new foundation is also
based on reforms that will make our
economy stronger and our businesses more
competitive reforms that will make
healthcare cheaper our financial system
more secure and our government less
burdened with debt in a global economy
we can't pursue this agenda in a vacuum
at the height of the financial crisis
the coordinated action we took with the
nations of the g20 prevented a global
depression and helped restore worldwide
growth and as we've recently witnessed
in Europe economic difficulties in one
part of the world can affect everybody
else and that's why we have to keep on
working with the nations of the g20 to
pursue more balanced growth that's why
we need to coordinate financial reform
with other nations so that we avoid a
global race to the bottom it's why we
need to open new markets and meet the
goal of my National Export initiative to
double our exports over the next five
years and it's why we need to ensure
that our competitors play fair and our
agreements are enforced this too is part
of building a new foundation now some of
you may have noticed that we have been
building this foundation without much
help from our friends in the other party
from our efforts to rescue the economy
to health insurance reform to financial
reform most of sat on the sidelines and
shouted from the bleachers they said no
to tax cuts for small businesses no to
tax credits for college tuition no to
investments in clean energy they said no
to protecting patients from insurance
companies and consumers from big banks
and some of this of course is just
politics
before I was even inaugurated the
congressional leaders the other party
got together and made a calculation that
if I failed they'd win so when I went to
meet with them about the need for a
Recovery Act in the midst of crisis they
announced they were against it before I
even arrived at the meeting before we
even had a health care bill a Republican
senator actually said if we're able to
stop Obama on this it will be his
Waterloo it will break him so those
weren't very hopeful signs but to be
fair a good deal of the other party's
opposition to our agenda has also been
rooted in their sincere and fundamental
belief about the role of government it's
a belief that government has little or
no role to play in helping this nation
meet our collective challenges it's an
agenda that basically offers two answers
to every problem we face more tax breaks
for the wealthy and fewer rules for
corporations the last administration
called this recycled idea the ownership
society but what it essentially means is
that everyone is on their own no matter
how hard you work if your paycheck isn't
enough to pay for college or health care
or childcare well you're on your own if
misfortune causes you to lose your job
or your home you're on your own and if
you're a Wall Street bank or an
insurance company or an oil company you
pretty much get to play by your own
rules regardless of the consequences for
everybody else now I've never believed
the government has all the answers
government cannot and should not replace
businesses as the true engine of growth
and job creation government can't
instill good values in a sense of
responsibility and our children that's a
parent's job
too much government can deprive us of
choice and burden us with debt poorly
designed regulations can choke off
competition in the capital that
businesses need to thrive I understand
these arguments and it's reflected in my
policies after all one third of the
Recovery Act we designed was made up of
tax cuts for families and small
businesses and when you think back to
the health care debate despite calls for
a single-payer government-run health
care plan we passed reform that
maintains our system of private health
insurance but I also understand that
throughout our nation's history we have
balanced the threat of overreaching
government against the dangers of an
unfettered market we've provided a basic
safety net because any one of us might
experience hardship at some time in our
lives and may need some help getting
back on our feet and we've recognized
that there have been times when only
government has been able to do what
individuals couldn't do and corporations
wouldn't do that's how we have railroads
and highways public schools and police
forces that's how we've made possible
scientific research that has led to
medical breakthroughs like the vaccine
for hepatitis B and technological
wonders like GPS that's how we have
social security and a minimum wage and
laws to protect the food we eat and the
water we drink and the air that we
breathe that's how we have rules to
ensure that mines are safe and yes that
oil companies pay for the spills that
they caused now there have always been
those who've said no to such protections
no to such investments there were
accusations that social security would
lead to socialism and the Medicare was a
government takeover there were bankers
who claimed the creation of federal
posite insurance would destroy the
industry and there were automakers who
argued that installing seatbelts was
unnecessary and unaffordable there were
skeptics who thought that cleaning our
water and our air would bankrupt our
entire economy and all of these claims
proved false all of these reforms led to
greater security and greater prosperity
for our people and our economy so what
was true then is true today as November
approaches leaders in the other party
will campaign furiously on the same
economic arguments they've been making
for decades fortunately we don't have to
look back too many years to see how
their agenda turns up for much of the
last 10 years we've tried it their way
they gave us tax cuts that weren't paid
for two millionaires who didn't need
them they gutted regulations and put
industry insiders in charge of Industry
oversight a short changed investments in
clean energy and education in research
and technology and despite all their
current moralizing about the need to
curb spending this is the same crowd who
took the record 237 billion dollar
surplus that President Clinton left them
and turned it into a record 1.3 trillion
dollar deficit so we know where those
ideas lead us and now we have a choice
as a nation we can return to the failed
economic policies of the past or we can
keep building a stronger future we can
go backward or we can keep moving
forward and I don't know about you but I
want to move forward I think America
wants to move forward now the first step
in building a new foundation that allows
us to move forward has been to address
the costs and risks that have made our
economy less competitive outdated
regulations
crushing healthcare costs and a growing
debt to start with we can't compete as a
nation if the irresponsibility of a few
folks on Wall Street can bring our
entire economy to its knees that's why
we're on the verge of passing the most
sweeping financial reform since the
Great Depression it's a reform that will
help prevent another AIG it will end tax
payer funded bank bailouts it contains
the strongest consumer protections in
history protections that will empower
Americans with the clear and concise
information they need before signing up
for a credit card or taking out a
mortgage the financial reform will not
guard against every instance of greed
and irresponsibility on Wall Street but
it will enshrine a new principle in our
financial system from now on instead of
competing to see who can come up with
the cleverest scheme to make the
quickest buck financial institutions
will compete to see who can make the
better product than the better service
and that's a competition that benefits
Wall Street and Main Street that's why
we need to get this legislation done
that's why we can't afford to go back we
have to move forward we also know we
can't compete in a global economy if our
citizens are forced to spend more and
more of their income on medical bills if
our businesses are forced to choose
between health care and hiring if state
and federal budgets are weighed down
with skyrocketing health care costs
that's why we finally passed health
insurance reform now let's be clear
costs of health care are not going to
come down overnight just because
legislation passed and in ever changing
industry like health care we're going to
continuously need to apply more
cost-cutting measures as the years go by
but once this reform is in full effect
middle-class families will pay
less for their health care and the worst
practices of the insurance industry will
end people with pre-existing medical
conditions will no longer be excluded
from coverage people who become
seriously ill will no longer be thrown
off their coverage for reasons contrived
by the insurance company tax payers will
no longer have to pay in the form of
higher premiums for trips to the ER by
uninsured Americans businesses will get
help with their health care costs in
fact small businesses are already
learning they're eligible for tax
credits to cover their workers this year
and with less waste and greater
efficiency in the system this reform
will do more to bring down the deficit
than any step we have taken in more than
a decade the other party has staked
their claim this November on repealing
these health insurance reforms instead
of making them work they want to go back
we need to move forward making health
care more cost efficient is critical
because it's also true we can't be
competitive as a nation if we remain
dragged down by our growing debt let me
talk about debt just for a second by the
time I took office we had a one-year
deficit of over one trillion dollars and
projected deficits of eight trillion
dollars over the next decade most of
this was the result of not paying for
two major tax cuts skewed to the wealthy
and a worthy but expensive prescription
drug program that wasn't paid for I
always find it interesting that the same
people who participated in these
decisions are the ones who now charge
our administration with fiscal
irresponsibility and the truth is if I
had taken office in ordinary times I
would have liked nothing more than to
start bringing down the deficits that
they create but we took office amid a
crisis and the effects of the recession
put a three trillion dollar hole
in our budget before I even walk through
the door additionally the steps that we
had to take to save the economy from
depression temporarily added more to the
deficit by about a trillion dollars of
course if we had spiraled into a
depression our deficits and debt levels
would be much worse now the economy is
still fragile so we can't put on the
brakes too quickly we have to do what it
takes to ensure a strong recovery a
growing economy will unquestionably
improve our fiscal health as will the
steps we take in the short term to put
Americans back to work and that's why I
signed a bill that will provide tax cuts
for small businesses that hire
unemployed workers that's why I've urged
Congress to pass a small business
lending fund so that small businesses
can get the credit they need to create
jobs and grow that's why i believe it's
critical we extend unemployment
insurance for several more months so
that Americans who've been laid off
through no fault of their own get the
support they need to provide for their
families and can maintain their health
insurance until they're rehired and we
have to work with state and local
governments to make sure they have the
resources to prevent likely layoffs of
hundreds of thousands of public school
teachers across the country over the
next few months but as we look ahead we
can't lose sight of the urgent need to
get our fiscal house in order there are
four key components to putting our
budget on a sustainable path maintaining
economic growth is number one health
care reform is number two the third
component is the belt-tightening steps
I've already outlined to reduce our
deficit by one trillion dollars starting
in 2011 we will enact a three-year
freeze on all discretionary spending
outside of national security something
that was never enacted in the last
administration we will allow the tax
cuts for the wealthiest Americans takes
fire we've gone through the budget line
by line and identified more than 120
programs for elimination
we've restored a simple budgeting rule
that every family and business
understands called pay-as-you-go and we
will charge the largest Wall Street
firms a fee to repay the American people
for rescuing them during the financial
crisis a fee that will bring down the
deficit by 90 billion dollars a P that
will bring down the deficit by 90
billion dollars over the next decade by
the way that 90 billion dollars
represents about 18 of the amount of
these banks will pay out in bonuses over
the same period of time now finally the
fourth component improving our fiscal
health is the bipartisan fiscal
commission that I've established it will
provide a specific set of solutions by
the fall to deal with our medium and
long-term deficit and I have to warn you
this will not be easy I know that some
like to make the argument that if we
would just eliminate pork barrel
projects and foreign aid we could
eliminate our deficit turns out such
spending makes up just three percent of
our deficit you combine all foreign aid
and all earmarks that's three percent of
our budget so meaning the deficit
challenge will require some very
difficult decisions about the largely
popular programs that make up the other
ninety seven percent it means we'll have
to sort through our priorities and
figure out what programs that we can do
without on this point I strongly agree
with my friends in the other part what I
don't agree with is the notion that we
should also sacrifice critical
investments in our people and our future
you know if you're a family whose
tightening your belt you will definitely
sacrifice going out to dinner but you're
not going to sacrifice saving for your
child's college education it's precisely
our investments in education and
innovation that will make America more
competitive in the 21st century
and we can't go back we've got to move
forward
that's why I've made education reform a
top priority because countries that
out-educate us today will out-compete us
tomorrow and so we want every citizen to
have the skills and training they need
in a global economy from the day that
you are born through whatever career you
may choose last year we launched a
national competition to improve our
schools based on a simple idea instead
of funding the status quo we will only
invest in reform reform that raises
student achievement that inspires
students to excel in math and science
and turns around failing schools that
steal the future of too many young
Americans and to achieve my goal of
ensuring America once more has the
highest proportion of college graduates
in the world by 2020 we passed a law
that will make college more affordable
by ending the unnecessary taxpayer
subsidies that go to financial
institutions for student loans that
means we're saving billions of dollars
that will go directly to students
including students right here at
Carnegie Mellon
it's a bill that will also revitalize
our community colleges which are a
career pathway to the children of so
many working families in addition to
training our workers for the jobs of the
future we're also investing in the
innovation that will create those jobs
here in America the research the
technology the infrastructure that will
secure our economic future right now as
we speak the Recovery Act is putting
Americans to work building a 21st
century America there's no reason China
should have the fastest trains or that
rural Pennsylvania should be without
high-speed Internet access we've got to
make those investments from the first
railroads to the internet interstate
highway system this nation has always
been built to compete so we're going to
invest and are investing right now in
new infrastructure expanding broadband
health information technology advanced
manufacturing facilities America's first
high-speed rail network we're also
investing in the ideas and technologies
that will lead to new jobs and entire
new industries consider what we've done
with clean energy the tax credits and
loan guarantees in the recovery act
alone will lead to seven hundred and
twenty thousand clean energy jobs in
America by 2012 720 thousand
I'll give you one example the United
States used to make less than two
percent of the world's advanced
batteries for hybrid cars by 2015
because of the investments that we made
we'll have enough capacity to make up to
forty percent of these batteries now
this brings me to an issue that's on
everybody's minds right now namely what
kind of energy future can ensure or a
long-term prosperity the catastrophe
unfolding in the Gulf right now may
prove to be a result of human error or
of corporations taking dangerous
shortcuts to compromise safety or a
combination of both and I've launched a
national commission so that the American
people will have answers on exactly what
happened but we have to acknowledge that
their inherent risks to drilling for
miles beneath the surface of the earth
and these are risks
these are risks that are bound to
increase the harder oil extraction
becomes we also have to acknowledge that
in America run solely on fossil fuels
should not be the vision we have for our
children and our grandchildren you know
we
we consume more than twenty percent of
the world's oil but have less than two
percent of the world's oil reserves so
without a major change in our energy
policy our dependence on oil means that
we will continue to send billions of
dollars of our hard-earned wealth to
other countries every month including
countries in dangerous and unstable
regions in other words our continued
dependence on fossil fuels will
jeopardize our national security it will
smother our planet and it will continue
to put our economy and our environment
at risk now I understand that we can't
end our dependence on fossil fuels
overnight that's why I supported a
careful plan of offshore oil production
as one part of our overall energy
strategy but we can pursue such
production only if it's safe and only if
it's used as a short-term solution while
we transition to a clean energy economy
and the time has come to aggressively
accelerate that transition the time has
come once and for all for this nation to
fully embrace a clean energy future
now that means continuing our
unprecedented effort to make everything
from our homes and businesses to our
cars and trucks more energy efficient it
means tapping into our natural gas
reserves and moving ahead with our plan
to expand our nation's fleet of nuclear
power plants it means rolling back
billions of dollars of tax breaks to all
companies so we can prioritize
investments in clean energy research and
development but the only way the
transition to clean energy will
ultimately succeed is if the private
sector is fully invested in this future
if capital comes off the sidelines and
the ingenuity of our entrepreneurs is
unleashed and the only way to do that is
by finally putting a price on carbon
pollution now many businesses have
already embraced this idea because it
provides a level of certainty about the
future and for those that face
transition costs we can help them adjust
but if we refuse to take into account
the full costs of our fossil fuel
addiction if we don't factor in the
environmental costs in the national
security costs and the true economic
costs we will have missed our best
chance to seize a clean energy future
the House of Representatives has already
passed a comprehensive energy and
climate dog and there's currently a plan
in the Senate a plan that was developed
with ideas from Democrats and
Republicans that would achieve the same
goal and Pittsburgh I want you to know
the votes may not be there right now but
I intend to find them in the coming
months I will continue to make the case
for a clean energy future wherever and
whenever I can I will work with anyone
to get this done and we will get it done
the next generation will not be held
hostage to energy sources from the last
century we are not going to move
backwards
we are going to move forward now this
overarching principle that we must
invest in and embrace the innovation and
technology of the future and not the
past that applies beyond our energy
policy that's why we've decided to
devote more than three percent of our
gdp to research and development to spur
the discovery of services and products
and businesses that we have yet to
imagine we've proposed making the
research and experimentation Tax Credit
permanent a tax credit that helps
businesses afford the high costs of
developing new technologies and new
products last year we made the largest
investment in basic research funding in
history the possibilities of where this
research might lead are endless imagine
a new treatment that kills cancer cells
but leaves healthy ones untouched
regenerative medicine that ends the
agonizing wait for an organ transplant
imagine a light weight vest for soldiers
and police officers that can stop armor
piercing bullets educational software
that's as effective and engaging as a
personal tutor intelligent prosthetics
that can enable a wounded veteran to
play the piano again and now imagine all
the workers and small business owners
and consumers who would benefit from
these discoveries we can't know for
certain what the future will bring we
can't guess with 100% accuracy what
industries and innovations will next
shape our world I'm sure there were
times when this city couldn't imagine
life without steel mills and heavy smog
that filled these streets and when that
industry shrank and so many jobs were
lost who could have guessed that
Pittsburgh would fare better than many
other Rust Belt cities Andrey emerged as
a center for
technology and green jobs healthcare and
education who would have thought that
the University of Pittsburgh Medical
Center's logo would one day adorn the
u.s. steel tower or that this institute
Carnegie Mellon would be the region's
largest employer all of this came to be
because as a community you prepared and
adapted and invested in a better future
even if you weren't always sure what
that future would look like and that's
what America does that's what we've
always done the interests of the status
quo will always have the most vocal and
powerful defenders at every level of
government there will always be
lobbyists for the banks or the insurance
industry that doesn't want more
regulation or the corporation that would
prefer to see more tax breaks instead of
more investments in infrastructure or
education and let's face it a lot of us
find the prospect of change scary even
when we know the status quo isn't
working for us but there is no natural
lobby for the clean energy company that
may start a few years from now there's
no natural lobby for the research that
may lead to a life-saving medical
breakthrough there's no natural lobby
for the student who may not be able to
afford a college education but if they
got one could end up making discoveries
that would transform America in the
world it's our job as a nation to
advocate on behalf of the America that
we hope for to make decisions that will
benefit the next generation even if it's
not always popular even if we can't
always see those benefits in the short
term we make decisions like this on
behalf of our own children
every single day and while it's harder
to do with an entire country is large
and diverse Azar's it's no less
important the role of government has
never been to plan every detail or
dictate every outcome and its best
government has simply knocked away
barriers to opportunity and laid the
foundation for a better future our
people with all their drive and
ingenuity always end up building the
rest if we can do that again if we can
continue building that foundation and
making those hard decisions on behalf of
the next generation I have no doubt that
we will leave our children the America
that we all hope for thank you very much
everybody god bless you god bless the
United States of America
you